bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7 8
week-end le magazine de vos idées
sorties et loisirs pour cette fin de
semaine et puis nous revenons également
sur les principaux sujets diffusés cette
semaine allez on démarre tout de suite
avec une exposition qui est se déroule
en ce moment et jusqu'au 4 mai à l'hôtel
de ville de Versailles une exposition
autour des éditions Le Lombard Aurélia
Debussy au commentaire
rendez-vous annuel des amateurs et
collectionneurs de bandes dessinées pour
sa sixième édition l'exposition BD de
Versailles métalonneur jusqu'au 4 mai
non pas un auteur mais toute une
collection et il s'agit de la collection
signée des éditions Le Lombard qui
célèbre cette année leur 20e
anniversaire elle compte aujourd'hui une
trentaine d'auteurs confirmés et
reconnus dans le paysage du neuvième art
l'exposition présente l'ensemble des
romans graphiques issus de la collection
à travers plus de centres originaux
cette exposition est particulière parce
qu'on monte la diversité des dessins du
fait qu'il y a un grand nombre de
dessinateurs il y a plus de 20 plus de
20 dessinateurs et plus d'une centaine
de planches originales et on y retrouve
donc un grand nombre de dessins et puis
surtout les palettes graphiques vraiment
différentes de ces auteurs on retrouve
des pattes complètement différentes
certains qui dessinent en couleur direct
d'autres qui sont en classiques d'autres
qui sont en avis d'autres qui sont
crayonnés il y a vraiment une diversité
du dessin et qui fait la richesse de
cette collection
loin des albums en série la collection
signée à la particularité de données
carte blanche aux auteurs pour raconter
une histoire en un ou deux volumes c'est
vraiment comme si on faisait un truc
ultra personnel sans exclusif suivi par
une contrainte soit éditoriale soit
commercial ici il y en avait pas quoi
c'est super important des expo comme ça
parce qu'on rencontre des gens on
rencontre des gens qui qui ont lu notre
bouquin parce qu'il faut savoir que
c'est un métier quand même un métier de
solitaire on travaille un peu on
travaille pendant des mois seul dans une
pièce à prendre un scénario à le mettre
en image et tout donc on en devient
presque à la fin du bouquin on en
devient presque associés quoi les
dessinateurs de BD ici ça nous pousse un
peu à rencontrer les gens à leur
demander pourquoi t'es un peu pourquoi
l'as-tu pris en rayon pourquoi l'as-tu
ouvert pourquoi tu aimes bien quelle
scène t'a plu est-ce que le rythme te
plaît donc c'est c'est super important
pour moi
et cette exposition va en parler un peu
plus longuement avec Yolan Turbet de
Love bonsoir vous êtes directeur des
affaires culturelles à la ville de
Versailles c'est la sixième expo BD qui
se tient dans la ville de Versailles
d'habitude vous aviez l'habitude de
d'inviter des plutôt des dessinateurs et
là c'est carrément une collection que
vous inviter effectivement en fait
pendant 5 ans on a mis à l'honneur un
dessinateur un dessinateur actuel qu'on
a invité à parmi les plus grands
dessinateurs ou scénariste d'ailleurs
puisqu'on a eu notamment les auteurs de
13 de l'Argo Winch de Thorgan donc
vraiment les plus grandes signatures du
moment qui était présente à Versailles
et cette année on a eu envie de changer
un petit peu on s'est dit on va pas en
inviter on va en inviter 20 et voilà
carrément exactement et c'est vrai que
le but de cette exposition BD c'est de
faire quelque chose d'un petit peu hors
des sentiers battus on ne sait pas un
festival comme la plupart du temps pour
la bande dessinée on est vraiment sur la
mise à l'honneur d'un travail notamment
d'un travail de scénario d'un travail
graphique de montrer que ces deux se
conjugue pour un vrai art donc le 9e art
et c'est vrai que les éditions du
Lombard ont une démarche un peu
particulière par rapport à beaucoup de
maisons d'édition qui est de mettre à
l'honneur cette rareté de mettre à
l'honneur ce travail des scénaristes et
des dessinateurs avec une collection à
part une collection signée qui a été
créée en 1994
que tous les auteurs qui intègrent cette
collection ne font qu'un seul ouvrage
pour cette collection donc on n'est pas
dans la loi des séries on n'est pas dans
quelque chose qui doit être forcément
très grand public dans quelque chose qui
doit être rentable on est dans quelque
chose qui doit être un petit peu
exceptionnel et un petit peu différent
du travail qu'il faut habituellement
souvent les dessinateurs les scénaristes
sont reconnus par par une pâte par
quelque chose qu'ils ont de
reconnaissable de spécifique et là ils
en sortent un petit peu et si vous me
passez l'expression ils se font plaisir
ils font vraiment quelque chose quelque
chose qui leur ressemble quelque chose
qui quelque chose qu'ils ont toujours eu
envie de faire
particulier du coup forcément très
intime puisque c'est une seule et très
intime c'est une seule œuvre c'est une
œuvre qui leur ressemble le plus qui
ressemble vraiment à ce qu'ils ont envie
de faire profondément et du coup une
maison d'édition donc en l'occurrence le
Lombard leur permet de le faire donc
souvent on a affaire à des thèmes très
intimes comme vous le disiez des thèmes
souvent durs on a représentation de la
vie telle qu'elle est des
représentations de rêve des
représentations du vide aussi parfois
qui est dans nos têtes voilà des choses
qui ne sont pas forcément faciles à
exprimer dans la bande dessinée mais là
que justement par cette collection un
petit peu à part le Lombard permet de
faire donc on a eu envie de de mettre à
l'honneur cette collection finalement on
connaît peu on connaît peu alors qu'elle
est assez exceptionnelle et en plus on a
vu sur les images à l'occasion de
reportage qui avait une grande diversité
en plus à la fois dans le dessin et je
présume dans l'écriture également de
cette collection et alors d'autant plus
intéressant c'est que on peut voir donc
une centaine je crois des 100 originaux
qui sont présentés en mairie de
Versailles je le rappelle jusqu'au 4 mai
alors d'autant plus intéressant
peut-être ce sont ces fameux séances
dédicaces puisque tous les week-ends
justement un auteur qui disait c'est un
vrai métier de solitaire d'être
dessinateur et donc ça leur fait du bien
visiblement à eux de venir rencontrer le
public et je présume que pour le public
c'est aussi intéressant de rencontrer
ces auteurs ses dessinateurs pour le
public c'est passionnant et là on me
dérange pas effectivement à la règle
quand c'est fixé depuis le début donc de
cette expo BD donc depuis six ans de la
rencontre avec l'auteur et la rencontrer
avec l'auteur c'est déjà de voir comment
est-ce que l'auteur travaille comment
est-ce qu'il dessine ça c'est quelque
chose dont on se rend pas forcément
compte il faut savoir que les
dessinateurs de BD de bande dessinée ne
font pas une simple dédicace mais faut
un vrai dessin enfin une vraie oeuvre
d'art en fait sur votre exemplaire que
que vous lui apportez donc on a vraiment
un exemplaire qui est qui est encore
plus mise en valeur et la voix in vivo
en live le travail de le travail de
l'auteur on a des gens qui viennent de
la France entière pour rencontrer ces
auteurs c'est quelque chose d'assez
impressionnant les auteurs effectivement
sont peu visibles ils le disaient même
sont très solitaires donc là voilà pour
une fois il rencontre le public ne le
font pas souvent donc il faut en
profiter d'habitude on le faisait le
premier weekend d'exposition et là il y
en a tellement que on le fait tous les
week-ends
Lefeuvre et Fred salsa c'est dos pardon
qui sont à l'honneur ce week-end il y en
a encore plein d'autres jusqu'au
jusqu'au 4 mai un mot également sur le
prix le prix espoir du neuvième art pour
la troisième année alors pour la
troisième on avait envie de voilà de
mettre à l'honneur des jeunes créateurs
les créateurs de les grands créateurs de
demain c'est assez cohérent d'ailleurs
avec l'ensemble de nos politiques
culturelles on essaye à la fois de
montrer ce qu'il y a de plus connu et
puis à la fois de montrer aussi
l'émergence dans tous les domaines et là
donc c'est l'émergence dans le 9e art et
donc chaque année Françoise Mazières le
député maire de Versailles remet deux
prix pour le meilleur scénario et un
pour le meilleur dessinateur voilà donc
cette année je crois que vous pouvez le
voir à l'écran si je ne me trompe pas
romain renard voilà renard qui est
l'auteur d'un très très belle ouvrage
Melville et puis Philippe nicloud
malheureusement je ne l'ai pas sur moi
c'est le dessinateur de Terra Australia
donc pareil ce sont des ouvrages assez
intimes donc qui ont été sélectionnés
par notre jury qui est composé de
scénaristes de grands noms de la bande
dessinée
on peut les on peut les rencontrer ou
alors eux on pouvait les rencontrer le
week-end dernier
ici si jamais ils reviennent ce seront
des simples visiteurs donc il faut les
repérer dans l'exposition alors la ville
de Versailles on connaît également son
salon du livre d'histoire où il y a
aussi beaucoup de dédicaces il y a
souvent des de nombreux auteurs qui
viennent ouais tout à fait là il y a le
donc ce salon avec dédicace ou les
week-ends
des grands événements exactement c'est
une volonté plus que des grands
événements c'est une volonté d'être
représentative de l'ensemble des
cultures et de l'ensemble des formes de
création donc on va avoir des choses
littéraires on va avoir beaucoup de
beaucoup de cinéma on va avoir beaucoup
de photographies de sculpture d'art
contemporain de bandes dessinées donc il
y a l'honneur en ce moment évidemment je
ne parle pas du théâtre la musique de la
danse une grande tradition dans les arts
vivants les arts du spectacle voilà mais
je dirais ça va effectivement tous les
événements montrent enfin si on prend
chaque événement on arrive à brasser
l'ensemble des cultures et puis l'idée
c'est d'aller au-delà de ces événements
c'est à dire d'avoir vraiment un soutien
à la création un soutien aux artistes un
soutien voilà assez différentes formes
de culture qui parfois sont très
intuitionnalisées parfois plus
émergentes et que le public d'autres
projets alors il y a beaucoup de projets
il y a beaucoup de projets
ce n'est plus un scoop on réfléchit sur
comment Versailles va pouvoir défendre
les musiques actuelles donc donc
effectivement dans les années qui
viennent Versailles aura sa salle de
musique salle de spectacle dédiée à la
musique vous savez qu'il y a une french
touch qui est essentiellement qui vient
beaucoup de Versailles donc Versailles
connu pour cela et c'est vrai que c'est
une action sur laquelle la ville n'était
pas encore très investie donc voilà
françois de Mazières lance un grand plan
pour défendre cette frenchotte et cette
Versailles Deutsch donc
des musiques actuelles des groupes on va
commencer on va commencer dès maintenant
au théâtre Montier en ayant des des
grands concerts on continue avec des
résidences artistiques et dans quelques
années notre grande salle de spectacle
donc à suivre d'actualité
c'est jusqu'au 4 mai à l'hôtel de ville
de Versailles avec de nombreuses
dédicaces tous les week-ends si vous
voulez rencontrer les auteurs en vrai
merci beaucoup à vous allez on va rester
du côté de Versailles avec les Journées
Européennes des Métiers d'Art l'occasion
de découvrir les métiers qui se cachent
au château de Versailles et notamment à
l'occasion de la restauration du bassin
de l'automne
Laurent Bouillot est ailleurs de Pierre
sa spécialité la restauration de
monuments historiques installé au cœur
du petit parc à Versailles il présente
aux visiteurs ses savoir-faire dans le
cadre des Journées Européennes des
Métiers d'Art cet événement annuel
organisé par tout en France invite le
public à découvrir pendant 3 jours des
métiers d'exception la restauration en
cours du bassin de la tonne et
l'occasion pour les visiteurs d'échanger
avec les artisans d'art sur leur
technique l'héritage de savoir-faire
élaborer au fil des siècles on essaye de
toujours de se conformer à la taille
d'époque d'être au plus près de ce qui
se faisait quand on aura monté
l'ensemble de la route il faut pas qu'on
voit les les éléments neufs au milieu
des éléments si il faut que tout soit
homogène donc il y a un travail de un
petit peu de vieillissement de patine
aussi on va on va mettre des couleurs à
l'aide de Lyon à l'aide de terre de
façon à colorer un petit peu la surface
de la pierre légèrement pour s'adapter
aux couleurs des pieds anciennes
effectivement la partie vue elle doit
être parfaite elle doit être taillée
exactement comme une pierre qui a été
taillée à l'époque de Louis XIV donc on
doit avoir la même taille la même
définition la même finition d'ouvrage la
finition se fait au maillet aussi avec
détaillant uniquement les outils qui
pouvaient être disponibles à l'époque on
va pas utiliser une machine moderne pour
la finition autre technique de
restauration celle des métaux cette
fois-ci plus moderne Philippe Pagnon
chaudronnier œuvre à la conservation du
décor sculpté de la fontaine qui abrite
les habitants des marais nous on a la
soudure aussi à City unique avec du
plomb pur donc
qui sont prêtes bien voilà sur ce genre
de sculpture on emploie donc les
techniques d'aujourd'hui pour restaurer
les oeuvres la difficulté c'est de
restaurer l'oeuvre sans la dénaturer
pendant toute la durée du chantier le
château de Versailles invite le public à
découvrir le travail exceptionnel des
artisans d'art les prochains rendez-vous
auront lieu les 16 et 23 mai puis le 19
juin
allez à partir de ce week-end ce
vendredi soir très précisément ce sont
les vacances de Pâques et peut-être
êtes-vous à la recherche d'idées pour
occuper vos enfants ou peut-être pour
vous occuper vous-même en tout cas pour
en parler des idées Sylviana bonsoir
vous êtes la directrice et vous êtes
venu à chaque fois avec plein d'idées
j'essaie d'avoir plein d'idées mais elle
existe oui mais donc je ne fais que vous
les divulguez et alors il y a plein de
choses à faire comme vous l'imaginez et
dans tous les styles d'activité donc on
va commencer par la serre aux papillons
les enfants peuvent obtenir une entrée
gratuite à la serre sur présentation
d'un dessin de papillon qui peut être
fait de façon différente au crayon au
feu feutre à la peinture même avec des
collages ils arrivent avec leur dessin
et donc et il rentre sur la serre aux
papillons qui est donc un endroit où les
papillons vivent en liberté qui sont sur
vos épaules absolument un endroit
magique c'est très exotique et on a
l'impression d'être extrêmement loin de
la région Île-de-France et surtout
forcément un micro climat qui fait très
vite forcément très température
c'est assez fascinant on va quitter la
séro papillon on va aller en extérieur
on va aller du côté de la pisciculture
de la Villette
c'est le nom du village qui se trouve au
nord du département au nord-ouest et
donc là on peut pêcher la truite on vous
donne le matériel
parents et enfants donc pêche la truite
au bord d'un étang et rassurez-vous ça
marche à tous les coups cette huit on
vous la prépare ensuite lorsqu'elle est
pêchée on vous donne un petit guide de
recettes parce que bien sûr le but de la
menace c'est aussi de la manger et dans
cette pisticulture de Villette il y a un
écomusé donc après avoir pêché sa truite
on visite écomusée ou on retrace toute
l'histoire de l'endroit et ça c'est une
super idée pour cette ce weekend parce
qu'il va faire très beau donc autant
autant en profiter le musée promenade
maintenant repart à l'intérieur voilà
alors là c'est c'est pas du tout la même
chose des ateliers donc au musée
promenade à Marly on peut faire deux
types d'ateliers qui sont tous les deux
basés sur le thème du printemps le
premier atelier est sur la création
d'un d'une suspension qui peut être en
papier en tissu avec des fils de fer
très très léger ça s'appelle léger comme
une plume et donc on a l'impression de
retracer l'histoire du Printemps du
soleil des
oiseaux des petits animaux de printemps
et puis il y en a un deuxième atelier là
qui est plus sur la musique c'est un
atelier donc musical qui s'appelle
printemps tourbillonnant tu sais pas
évocateur tout ça et là ce sont des
percussions des instruments à cordes qui
évoquent les bruits du printemps donc au
musée promenade de Marly-le-Roi hop on
fait encore un saut de puce à nous on
fait des sauts de plus partout dans le
département on va maintenant du côté du
château de Rambouillet oui alors on
descend plus au sud à Rambouillet alors
au Château de Rambouillet les prémices
de Pâques puisque c'est dans pas très
longtemps et donc on accompagne madame
la cloche qui elle va disposer les eaux
et justement il faut y aller pour la
rencontrer c'est ça madame la cloche
elle va elle va disposer ses petits œufs
pour qu'on vienne alors les chercher
dans une semaine
et donc on la compagne et bien sûr en
passant on a son petit œuf et il y a
aussi des des ateliers
un petit peu plus classique c'est enfin
c'est pas un atelier c'est un jeu de
piste et on est les aventuriers du temps
et on apprend à créer sa machine à
remonter le temps voilà et bien sûr à
Pâques le parc du château de Rambouillet
va proposer la chasse aux œufs également
ce dimanche 20 avril la veille du lundi
forcément dimanche de Pâques les
aventuriers du temps ça fait ça fait
envie de jeu autant du temps alors
effectivement puisqu'on parle de Pâques
à des animations on va dire chocolaté ah
oui c'est la chasse aux œufs la
traditionnelle chasse aux œufs alors il
y en a un peu partout il y en a une à la
ferme de Gally ouvrez bien l'oeil y en a
partout donc la ferme de Gally là on a
des milliers d'eux qui ont été parsemés
dans la ferme qui sont des œufs en
plastique de couleur et qu'on échange
ensuite contre des œufs et des petites
figurines chocolatées et bien sûr il
faut surtout pas oublier tous les
ateliers qui existent toujours ateliers
filage de la laine fabrication du jus de
pomme tous les ateliers classiques de la
ferme de Gally et surtout si on veut
être sûr de ne pas faire la queue on
achète en ligne son billet et comme ça
on l'a d'avance on arrive et on peut
directement on peut aller directement
chercher ses œufs et prendre les œufs le
plus vite possible
allez on retourne à la Bergerie
Nationale de Rambouillet oui alors à la
Bergerie nationale c'est la même chose
là il y a un jeu de existe qui existe
une course d'orientation pardon c'est
pas tout à fait pareil une course
d'orientation et là c'est la même chose
course d'orientation qui va vous
permettre de découvrir
toute la bergerie mais pour trouver ses
œufs également et la bergerie et comme
on le sait c'est ce sont les animaux la
traite des vaches et on découvre tout ça
tout en cherchant les autres de Pâques
d'accord donc ça c'est la Bergerie
Nationale de Rambouillet voilà course
d'orientation le zoo de Thoiry aussi qui
s'y met donc il s'y met depuis longtemps
d'ailleurs ils s'y met depuis 35 ans
donc ce qui continue
ça et ce sont pas moins de 9000 oeufs de
Pâques qui sont parsemés dans le parc de
Thoiry parc zoologique et donc on les on
les cherche les enfants les cherche et
on en donne aussi aux animaux parce que
c'est pas pour les animaux également
donc des œufs à base de jus de fruits
des œufs à base de viande pour les
carnivores
chocolat pour les animaux
les animaux ils ont ce qu'ils aiment et
c'est rigolo de les regarder manger
leurs œufs pour pas que aussi t'as pas
oublié
allez on termine sur la France Miniature
elle en cours c'est tout près d'ici
voilà alors
du chocolat
mais personne n'oublie pas qu'un c'est
une belle opportunité de manger ce qu'on
aime le chocolat tout le monde l'aime et
donc c'est le musée du chocolat des
chocolatiers et donc ça sera une belle
occasion de découvrir l'histoire du
chocolat de déguster de tester de
d'éveiller ses sens et
donc en même temps on découvre les
animations classiques
le le village de France les régions de
France comme d'habitude la ronde des
autos qu'on a vu tout à l'heure qui est
pour les plus petits et puis les petits
puisqu'on en parle auront l'occasion de
déguster un chocolat chaud d'accord bon
alors si on s'organise bien
deux heures par jour on peut tous les
faire un week-end de Pâques avec du
chocolat moi c'est du chocolat
merci beaucoup d'être venu sur le passé
ce weekend vous allez donc des idées des
idées pour cette semaine de vacances de
Pâques merci beaucoup allez autre
activité également à pratiquer pendant
les vacances le bowling les anciens
cinéma Gaumont de l'espace Saint-Quentin
ont été transformés en bowling avec 15
pistes à l'inauguration a eu lieu le 9
avril et nous y étions quelques jours
avant
les amateurs de bowling vont retrouver
leurs habitudes installées depuis 2007 à
Skywest à Montigny-le-Bretonneux
l'établissement avait quitté le centre
en janvier 2013 pour prendre possession
en novembre dernier de ses nouveaux
locaux à l'espace Saint-Quentin dans les
anciennes salles du cinéma Gaumont 5
mois de travaux ont été nécessaires pour
tout aménager ça a été un gros
investissement ça a été surtout très dur
parce que il a fallu descendre tout le
matériel dans les sous-sols dans les
sous-sols des anciens cinéma et ça s'est
fait à la main et ça a été un peu épique
reste maintenant à retrouver une
clientèle par rapport à la fréquentation
enregistrée Skywest le chiffre a été
divisé par deux mais le gérant espère
fidéliser rapidement de nouveaux
amateurs grâce à ses 15 pistes ces 8
billards et à la multiplication des
propositions d'animation nous avons un
espace de réception je dirais les zones
de consommation une salle de réunion qui
sont plus vastes et donc on a plus de
possibilités de recevoir des clients de
façon conviviale et agréable on a deux
grandes sites de clientèle chez
bowlingstar c'est d'une part la famille
et d'autre part les entreprises et pour
pouvoir aussi bien les entreprises que
la famille lorsqu'ils sont en groupe il
nous fallait de l'espace qu'on n'avait
pas forcément et qu'on a maintenant le
lieu emploi 6 salariés Robert Capet
envisage prochainement une autre
embauche le bowling fait partie d'un
groupe national qui dispose de 20
établissements en France
et retour maintenant sur l'actualité de
la semaine écoulée on va du côté de
Magny-les-Hameaux pour une opération de
nettoyage
une journée consacrée au bien de la
nature le 5 avril la commune de
Magny-les-Hameaux a donné rendez-vous à
ses citoyens pour le traditionnel
nettoyage de printemps un nettoyage qui
débutait par un stand d'information sur
le parvis de la mairie l'objectif
dialoguer et apprendre sur le tri des
déchets dessins animés pédagogiques jeux
de tri ou échantillon une association
accueillait le public pour faire
comprendre l'urgence de la situation il
est temps que les gens prennent
conscience de la pollution qui peut être
évitée grâce au tri on a de plus en plus
de poubelles on peut arriver jusqu'à 500
kg de bordure ménagères par habitant en
France par an c'est énorme quatre
parcours de nettoyage démarrer ensuite
de l'Hôtel de Ville réunissant 50
personnes jeunes et moins jeunes de
parcours en lisière de forêt et de
parcours en cœur de ville avec le même
but sensibiliser le public à la
protection de l'environnement
on a la chance sur Manila mot d'avoir
beaucoup d'espaces verts et justement on
se rend compte au travers de ces espaces
verts qui a quand même pas mal de
déchets dessus c'est un petit peu
moelleuse agréable pour eux pour pour
jouer pour s'amuser donc le l'idéal
c'est les responsabiliser à ce niveau là
et qui sache que c'est à eux de
préserver aussi l'environnement dans
lequel ils sont c'est pas la première
fois qu'on qui participent c'est ça fait
plusieurs années qu'on le fait et je
trouve ça utile quoi en fin d'après-midi
les déchets étaient réunis sur le parvis
pour un tri métaux verts et plastique
séparé le tout était ensuite acheminé
vers la déchetterie
ce 7 8 ce week-end presque terminé avant
de nous quitter on va ajouter un coup
d'œil sur l'agenda de ce weekend et on
va partir on va rester du côté de
Manille des hameaux pour les stylules le
festival urbain qui démarre ce samedi
sur l'esplanade de Gérard Philipe des
14h il y aura des artistes des danseurs
des musiques musiciens des riders et des
graffeurs voilà et puis à noter
également que toute la semaine prochaine
à Manille et hameaux il y a aussi des
ateliers alors musique maintenant Tiken
jahk Fakoly Mark son grand retour sur la
scène musicale avec la sortie d'un
nouvel album et sera la batterie de
Guyancourt ce samedi soir et puis pour
ceux qui aiment peut-être le style plus
classique les cœurs de la Pléiade
interpréteront des œuvres de Mozart
medanson ou encore un capella samedi
soir également mais cette fois c'est au
prisme a Élancourt allez ce 78 merci de
votre attention je vous souhaite un
excellent weekend profitez surtout du
très beau temps qui s'annonce à très
vite